bonsoir bonsoir à vous monsieur lavaud
comment est ce que vous avez reçu
d'abord ses propos du général larsson
j'utilise surpris choqués insulté
offertes par ce genre de commentaire là
sachant au fait qu'un joli coup tel
qu'il était il était on a utilisé
authentique c'était que toujours sur
lequel il ya pensé c'est pas été pris
par surprise il le répétait d'autres
occasions lequel durée puisque au logis
si le pot fait alors et voici c'est un
constat que lui qui est le plus haut
gradé des forces armées parle de cette
façon si ça nous dit beaucoup sa culture
pas seulement qu'à l'intérieur des faces
la culture du haut commandement et
services tic pourquoi aussi que jusqu'à
maintenant
malgré le fait qu sera portage choc du
magazine d'actualité en mairie de 2014
et le rapport de madame deschamps moi
même j'ai écrit plusieurs occasions aux
autorités ministérielles you jamais rien
que les faits et juste à mes temps on se
traîne les pieds on attendait réagit pas
de la façon qu'on devrait réagir et le
bâchage qu'on envoie aux victimes dont
70% d'entre elles ne rapportent pas
leurs assauts c'est que les choses les
choses vont rester comme elles le sont à
leurs yeux manque une perte de confiance
totale dans le système de justice
militaire et plus particulièrement dans
la chaîne de commandement donc penser
qu'il que que gerald ça ne reconnaît pas
la gravité de cette toute cette question
l'agression sexuelle dans l'armée
s'il ne reconnaît je pense pas qu'il a
pris les mesures jusqu'à maintenant un
est certainement le seul madame
deschamps qui l'avait lui-même en bac
est offert rapport de fait dire sur la
commande à sion et elle avait fait un
sondage à peu près 500 personnes
le message était très éloquent très très
robuste on lui disait précisément où
c'étaient des problèmes qu est ce qui
devait être fait et à ce moment là il a
écarté la majorité la grande majorité
ces recommandations et en accepter deux
seulement
et pour le reste du temps c'est à
l'étude sont approuvés en principe et
voici
et c'est seulement lorsque un ressac la
porte du public qu'on que lui même et
son agente major général whitecross a
décidé aux fins d'examiner de visites et
de parler aux gens alors qu' il était
nécessaire de prendre des mesures
immédiates et est très robuste ceux ci
note n'a pas eu d'effet n'a toujours pas
été fait
et le système est toujours en place et
une victime ce soir n'est pas plus à
l'abri qu'elle l'était lorsque madame
deschamps a subi sur l'apport lorsque
madame merci et qu'alstom monsieur
gaston qui ont fait le reportage de
l'oin à sa scène aux collègues de
l'actualité mais alors est ce qu'on
pensait que l'armée peut s'attaquer au
problème
il peut y avoir un changement de 2 à la
tête de l'armée parce que maintenant
plusieurs personnes demandent sa
démission de façon le général lawson
doit quitter en juillet mais est-ce que
ce sera suffisant un changement de garde
à la direction l'armée mais mme galipeau
je ne pense pas littéralement je ne
pense pas c'est le système comme tel qui
est vicié yves ici pour une bonne raison
nous avons un système de justice
militaire qui est fait pour pour sévir
contre des gens qui ont des camps d
offense au code de discipline chère
qu'un code de discipline
alors tant les policiers militaires que
ceux qui travaillent à l'intérieur du
système de justice militaire
il porte une femme ils portent
allegiance ans la haute chaîne de
commandement leur promotion de leur
carrière tout il dépend alors ils sont
là et leurs objectifs leur fidélité et
leur loyauté est différente et ce qu'il
faut faire c'est de retourner à la case
départ
en 1998 les autorités militaires
canadiennes ne va pas au jour des
élections que ce soit pour faire enquête
ou pour poursuivre un assaillant devant
le tribunal militaire
ces échanges et ça s'est fait très
discrètement sans aucun débat devant le
parlement
en 1998 il s'agit de retourner à la case
départ
la personne malade à volonté politique
pour ça ce drapeau ça prend d'abord noté
politique et je pense et j'espère du
moins et une ligne et 7 premier ministre
sont conscients maintenant qu'avec tous
les layracais qu'on a qu'on a vu qu'on a
entendues dont celui d'hier
il s'amène pas grand chose on va se
retrouver devant des caméras dans
quelques mois seulement après que madame
deschamps façon à part il ya eu deux
niveaux une agression sexuelle qui a eu
lieu au collège militaire de kingston le
problème n'est pas réglé gadio cour
martiale présentement qui ont pris place
aussi au collège militaire royal de
kingston alors là choses perdurent
il est temps maintenant des états dit
les autorités certainement politique
l'autorité civile prenne le contrôle et
donne aux canadiens canadiennes des
pères et les mères dont les garçons il
félicien dans les fosses l'assurance au
fait que ceux ci vont servir avec le
respect la dignité une gens de sécurité
et si jamais ils sont victimes de ce
genre de choses là les autorités civiles
policière et et de jeu ces jeux vont
prendre les choses en main vous serez
entendu merci beaucoup monsieur rapport
merci à vous